- So you mentioned you
were born in England
and you grew up in Canada, right?
So you just became a US
citizen though, right?
- Yes, three days after my birthday.
Yes, there was a lot to celebrate.
- I mean.
- I finally became a citizen,
and proudly--
- Was the test hard?
'Cause I've had friends take
it and they're like, it's,
and I feel like maybe I wouldn't pass it,
but I mean, I
(laughing)
- You have to study for it,
everybody says poo poo,
oh no, it's not hard.
It, it's hard and they're
tricky little questions
and at night I, they have
this app they give you,
you know, when you put
in your application.
So at night I would test myself
to see if I knew the answers.
Do you wanna, do you wanna try it?
- I do, what was one
of the questions like?
Okay, I want, I just want to
see if you can pass, like.
- Okay.
Well, this is, I picked two
tricky kind of ones
- Okay.
- that I thought you might like.
One of them is how many amendments
are there to the Constitution?
- How many amendments?
- Yeah
- There's,
is the amount we needed.
(buzzing)
(laughing)
(dinging)
- Wrong!
You don't get to become a citizen.
- You know what luckily born in Texas.
(laughing)
So I didn't have to take it.
- Do you want to try another one?
- Yes.
- Try your luck?
- I can't wait to fail, Kim.
I love this.
- Well, you're very competitive.
- I am, I'm losing, I'm all right with it.
- Okay, good.
Healthy ego, so here's
the second question.
How many voting members
are there of the house?
- Of the house?
As many that the house needed.
(buzzing)
(laughing)
- You definitely didn't pass.
- Like for a billion dollars,
I'm looking at people
right now all over going,
I'm gonna say.
- I don't know.
- Yeah, the answer is 435.
(dinging)
- Sure, see Weiss was wrong too.
He said 100,
not one US citizen in this room knew,
like born here,
not one of us knew the answer to that.